sie kannten ja rudi assauer persönlich
wie haben sie ihn erlebt ja ich hatte
ich aber eine veranstaltung
kennengelernt und ich habe ihn als
unglaubliche lieben großzügigen menschen
kennengelernt aber der natürlich auch
große ängste mit sich herumgetragen hat
weil zu der zeit wo ich ihn
kennengelernt habe war ja gerade die ja
demenz diagnose gestellt worden
das hat natürlich bei ihm grosse ängste
auch ausgelöst und verunsicherung wir
hatten dann auch noch darüber gesprochen
dass er auch vielleicht noch eine rede
hält da hatte er dann auch von abgesehen
weil wie gesagt mit dem text hatte er
glaube ich dann auch bedenken gegen
sicher auch viel mit dem thema demenz
wie oft kommt das denn vor das ja
vielleicht demenzkranke beraubt werden
ja also das kann tatsächlich sehr häufig
vor also es nimmt zu also das berichten
uns auch immer wieder juristen
es gibt ja mehrere möglichkeiten was man
machen kann also ich hätte jetzt zum
beispiel persönliche nassauer geraten
weil er ja doch über ein großes vermögen
verfügt hat dass er diese
vorsorgevollmacht was ja viele gar nicht
wissen
man sollte eine neutrale person noch mit
heranziehen also das heißt wenn man
jetzt man kann ja natürlich eine
vertraute person kinder aufnehmen
aber dass man auf jeden fall zusätzlich
noch vielleicht einen rechtsanwalt oder
eine neutrale person die so ein bisschen
den überblick auch darüber hat mit
reinzieht weil es ist ja auch für den
angehörigen besser weil dieses thema ist
einfach so groß und man gerät wir wissen
alle es gibt immer situationen im leben
wo man vielleicht dann plötzlich geld
braucht man kann die person nicht mehr
fragen und man gerät dann schnell
tatsächlich in eine geschichte rein die
dann auch schon straftatbestand untreue
unterschlagung oder so und von daher
würde ich immer dazu raten für wenn man
so eine vorsorgevollmacht macht
möglichst auch früh weil es ist ja
natürlich auch wichtig dass man dazu
noch voll geschäftsfähig ist auch gerade
so wir werden auch oft gefragt mit den
testamenten wie ist es eigentlich also
man muss um ein testament zu machen muss
man voll test hier fähig sein aber die
notare sind gar nicht so ausgebildet im
medizinischen das heißt sie könnte es
auch nur nach guten glauben dann auch
entscheiden und da ist einfach ganz
wichtig dass man möglichst auch ein
ärztliches attest hat also gerade wenn
es die diagnose der mensch und gibt
möglichst ein ärztliches attest mit
vorliegt weil sonst ist man hinterher
tatsächlich soweit
dass auch die ja im grunde die
testamente angerichtet werden können
und dann muss das gericht einen
sachverständigen gutachten dann
erstellen
das ist sehr kompliziert und die
gerichte entscheiden auch oft so sehr
sie die übergänge sind sehr schwimmend
also das heißt bei einer leichten demenz
kann es sein man ist noch
testierfähigkeit gutachten festgestellt
worden ist okay es ist zum beispiel
schon verlust von hirnmasse da und man
muss auch schon medikamente nehmen kann
es trotzdem sein dass das gericht im
nachhinein durch den sachverständigen
gutachten dann entscheidet das man doch
noch das tier fähig war
und das wissen halt vielen dingen
deswegen sollte man wirklich darauf
achten dass man eigentlich ein
ärztliches attest mit hat und immer so
früh wie möglich
und gerade wenn auch vielleicht
angehörige angst haben dass auch ihr
liebster lanier mensch mit demenz
sozusagen ihr angehöriger geklaut werden
könnte dann gibt es ja auch immer noch
die möglichkeit dass man gerichtlich
seinen sohn ein bewegungs vorbehalt
beantragt was auch wirklich eine gute
möglichkeit ist das heißt der angehörige
bleibt so geschäftsfähig in dem sinne
dass er brötchen kaufen kann oder
zeitungen aber große geschäfte sind dann
einfach nicht mehr möglich
beziehungsweise können rückgängig
gemacht werden das betrifft zum beispiel
viele die angst haben wenn die pflegerin
zum beispiel gibt's ja oft dass dann der
ältere herr schenk zu einer pflegerin
irgendwie eine teure kette oder wir
haben es auch gehabt ein auto und dann
kann man wenn man dieses vorher
festgelegt hat kann man diese ganzen
käufer auch rückgängig machen das würde
ich auch immer empfehlen dankeschön
claudia affäre ausführlichen
schilderungen vielen dank